[Music]
yeah I'm not hearing the best reviews
yeah you didn't watch it dude no oh is
this our first time talking about it
since they've had sex since it's been
released since the video okay here's my
thing I have an impossible mission right
there
the
wait
I can't look talk about this Mark take
it down
but Mark but you can keep it up but you
you're getting too locked in you you're
acting a little homeschool yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so
um I didn't realize that we haven't done
a pod since uh yeah Lena got Twisted
it's a guy's wife you can't just say
some guy's wife got her I think you can
if he did it if he orchestrated it you
gotta be respectful dude
yeah we can't just say that some girl
got [__]
[Laughter]
but for real though how do we describe
how Jason love put the bone and Bone
apart
I can't say that we can't talk about
that you can't you sound perspective for
what it is can we talk about her being
an absolute Champion yo this is what I
hate like what was going on the internet
like the expectations were way too high
that like
sorry can I just have a sentence
that weekend they call Barbie mid oh
that was crazy yeah she like I've said
in the past only men in Russia outside
of Russia this is one of the most
beautiful women
on the planet Earth they called Herman
listen if Letta if you're being called
mid the same week that the Internet
calls Margot Robbie mid yeah take that
with a grain of salt take that with a
grain of salt do them in or or a pillar
so what did lot take yeah was it was a
pillow yeah he took a whole pill he took
a pillow take that [__] with a pillar if
you need to as well while we're being
biblical on the pot yeah my point is
come on man like Margot Robbie mid a sex
scene where Lena is taking an absolutely
he's thinking about his performance he's
like wait a minute if that's mid what am
I doing
I don't watch porn so maybe I'm off here
like what are we expecting what are we
expecting to happen
like the dick went into the [__] right
this is how you know porn's too crazy
what what do we need people are like oh
there was an actor she wasn't a sister
of a brother that was a boss of someone
you need porn to be too crazy now
academics bro
academics responding they're not
watching live the porn and doing the
play-by-play as if it was a boxing match
was one of the funniest things I've ever
seen about entire life so good she's
getting dizzy the ref might have to come
here and stop it
bro hey what can we play that it was
[__] incredible
uh yeah I'll pull it up in the meantime
though I saw this fire ad in Brooklyn
speaking of the Barbie movie
that's the whole billboard oh yeah the
whole block all about it you did a half
ago
there's some graffiti right to the right
of that truck yeah why is it all white
yeah I don't know I don't know anything
about it not she seems like a smile has
anything to do with me graffiti artist
would do that that's how you know we're
not the only ones though
that's it right there bro I'm I'm
actually really happy to see that
foot fetishing which is disgusting
called a fetish it's the most normal
thing in the universe has become popular
I'm happy that all these other people
can now Embrace what they've always
loved for so but they put in like
bushwicks same thing pedophiles say
again
they say the same [__] with that movie
that's up wait they like Barbie no the
other movie oh the freedom yeah there we
go they're like oh they're happy that
it's being normal
because he's [__] billboard you
almost said to me
you just gotta go with the stuff
I thought he had a good one
[Music]
the same way
he pulled a gym in the office
should be trying to think like how do I
try this [__]
no but y'all weird for that y'all weird
people nah y'all like it man it's all
good don't worry y'all gonna get there
one day it is what it is like
Christianity you fight now
right now but one day you gonna need us
you're gonna need the good Christians
and Muslims too
bro I can't find his academics video
sorry dude ah [__] you I know oh wait I
posted on Twitter anywho so what do we
think what do we think how much do we
think they make it I think that's really
what it comes down to that's what we
need to know that's what the internet
needs to know what I think I think they
charge too little I thought it was five
bucks or something yeah I saw the
website it's 75 off I was like you can't
get your wife [__] and then give a
discount this is my wife we're raising
the rates it's Black Friday
hmm
that was good I gotta get back come on
is it Black Friday
[Laughter]
oh is it yeah oh wow we didn't yeah
religion
[Laughter]
oh I don't know no Black Friday does
have to do with religion that's when
Jesus died and then he rises three days
later
he's trying
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's good Friday but it is the same
Friday or no no
the college is getting stupid
I'm confused here Good Friday is when
Jesus died it was in April that's a
religious day that's a good Friday oh
Sunday and there's no sale Easter Sunday
is the day he came back three days later
this is religion
the day after Thanksgiving Thanksgiving
got nothing to do with Jesus hey did
y'all know this this is crazy hey hey
did you all know that Easter and
Thanksgiving are different hey do you
know what's even crazier none of them
are in July
those holidays are now I just want to
let everybody know in case you ever get
buying your turkey you're the most
religious person ever bro you think
every holiday is for Jesus I respect I'm
Orthodox what'd you think fourth of July
was
I mean Jesus is Independence no that's
when The Four Horsemen came yeah that's
why the fourth that's where the four
horsemen came
[Laughter]
my boobs are back
now
you guys don't think that I I did [__]
okay okay okay okay so anyway how much
do we think that they made
I think they cleared a million I mean
that's it
yeah but their name is everywhere not
that much people oh okay good they got a
brand Equity yeah we didn't make money
but we got brand Equity I don't know I
mean as it stands right now I mean I
purchased it because I'm not going to
steal from the friend of the show we
should donate honestly but it is on
spank bang right now for free that's the
thing yo how did you not I mean that
[__] was on Twitter for free but I'm
assuming that's a commercial and they're
not really going after it to try to get
people in a plug talk get them into all
that [__]
I think a lot of people have watched it
I mean I wonder how many views this has
right now I bet you could tell
I can't see that [__] I mean this is
cool so if you guys know what plug talk
is plug talk is basically a show that
they do where Lena and Adam will
interview a porn star and then they will
[__] them because what we want from porn
actresses
is their life story
yeah it was a little dark but I guess
that is part of of what they were doing
they had to make 10 million I mean like
I don't no I don't think I don't know
man that's the thing how many people
have to buy it for 10 million what's the
math
how much was it I know I shouldn't know
this 20 000 would be a hundred thousand
so that'd be 200 000 at five dollars a
piece to get a million it's two million
people two million people would need to
pay five dollars each they did not
wow now I guess the idea is that you
subscribe and you stay subscribed and
you forget and you forget
so maybe the idea is like if it's such a
small number I won't even go back and
look at it if it was 25 bucks
immediately canceling yeah
hmm
what do you guys think what do you guys
think what do you guys think I think
like a mill probably not worth it
yes
you're the only one who's not married
what you would for your wife because you
don't have a wife yet okay what dollar
amount we can act enough oh yeah how
much how much for someone to turn your
wife's guts into lasagna what is the
price point and is it more or less than
for you to be gay
um not on this you guys do it you guys
we can have wives bro we can't answer
this question why not you got this yeah
because we actually have y's We're not
gonna put a number on our wives head
yeah
yeah but it's different
yeah yeah he's wild he's wild yeah
yeah
why is this a problem for you you have
no one Priceless Jesus Christ that [__]
made me feel lonely yeah can you try
that again that was too that was too
mean anything teach just tried a nice
America why do you say that why you hate
Douglas we'll edit it and then try it I
just don't like that he's putting up
this fight for this imagine
everything's gonna exist in yeah but
then you say hey I didn't know you at
the time is obviously very different
it's a much higher number I didn't know
what love was priceless I don't care
about how much money never because
that's a valid answer yeah you just
answered it like that that's all you got
to say miles you don't feel like you're
that principal no I didn't want this to
turn on me let's not do this no miles
what's the number love is priceless
stuff love is priceless come on come on
come on come on what's your number I
don't have a number that my wife would
get rinsed out bro okay how much for a
guy to [__] in your wife's mouth
like what's the number for a guy to kiss
your wife I don't with his dick his dick
too many stuff just Just a Kiss yeah
he takes off her dress now come on Miles
no uh none I wouldn't play I think you
would go for a kiss just a guy kissing
what if she was an actress never
one billion dollars one billion dollars
so we're talking hey there we go okay
one billion dollars a kiss with tongue
I mean
you got to get in there girl yeah
we're on the board what have you talked
about that or what would you ever kiss a
woman in a film
you flipped it on yourself
sex scenes yeah yeah he already has
intimacy coordinator yes yes no
[Laughter]
um
yeah what do you mean like would I do
yeah yeah why not
I mean it's gonna piss my wife off but
yeah of course I mean I piss her off but
I mean she'd probably like it not to be
that
you know what I mean but but the girls
if the girl's hot if she's an ugly
[__] oaf then no I'm gonna say I have
to respect my wife
right
you know what I mean what if you were
like had to or you couldn't do the movie
and it's with your hero and you had to
suck a hot girl's toe
wait wait wait wait wait oh as part of
the movie or just what
another part of the movie yeah you got
to do a text
because maybe I don't know yeah yeah I'd
have to suck a hot girl's toe yeah like
like liquor going down her foot like do
that I'm not into that I don't want to
suck it I'll kiss it a lot I'll kiss it
a lot
I'll cover it in smooches and kisses
and kisses
no I'm definitely covered in smooches
and kisses and then rub my fingers in
between the toes
I'll do fast like I'll definitely do
that
don't say webbing I'll definitely Gap it
up and snap one with a foot I'll
definitely do that cultural purposes
only yeah for a movie yeah obviously if
you had to yeah but not if it's some orc
[__] [__] you know I'm not gonna do
that that's that'd be disgusting so I
won't do that oh you could just have
your girl be a stunt double for the
actress and then everyone wins yeah
that's perfect yeah everyone my wife
she's more private
no no that'd be better not against stump
double so if you want to get some more
stunt doubles in on the action do you
have an identical twin
uh yeah I don't know what would you go
would you not do a kiss scene
no I would I did yeah Mark did honestly
glad you said it for like a [__]
[__] cheating dude dude
it's interesting what a great loophole
no this is I was dating this is in
college I don't care oh you're dating
her you're
I'm married to my wife dude no you're
dating oh you guys are boyfriend and
girlfriend we were dating what does that
mean I mean yeah boyfriend and
girlfriend yes okay you're together in
college and you cheated on her
for your dreams of Fame and success dude
yeah I had to do it for the scene how do
we know if the two characters even like
each other
Adam 21 right here
this is crazy okay was she hot
yeah
[Laughter]
but this girl was a you know she was
fine but my girls did you get did you
get Brookie I felt a brick no you didn't
like a smiled Lego brick it was a Lego
brick it was a brick dude did you really
get a break no I was so nervous he was
the scene it was terrified can I tell
you something why it is cheating for
sure no it's not I did I said no you
can't tell me you can make no money for
me like a college movie or whatever and
the girl was the director and she casted
me and in the movie I had to hook up
with somebody else or something oh no
this story is falling apart
I forgot